[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 y ya está comiendo el estudio
rosa pérez más de burros a muy buena
mañana de jueves vamos a centrar la
sección del día de hoy en el boom de los
sindicatos esto en eeuu así titulan un
artículo publicado en el diario punto es
en colaboración con the gardian
exactamente buenos de a raúl porque
según una encuesta de gallup la
aprobación del movimiento sindical en
eeuu está en su punto más alto en un 68
por ciento el punto más alto desde
1965 cuando estaba en el 71 por ciento y
el punto más bajo en esta secuencia
histórica fue en el 2009 cuando la
aprobación era de un 48 por ciento bien
esta tendencia al alza en la aprobación
del movimiento sindical no se refleja
sin embargo en una mayor afiliación de
momento pero como decíamos si es una
tendencia ya que en muchas grandes
empresas como apple starbucks o a manson
no para mencionar algunas de las más
paradigmáticas los trabajadores se han
empezado a organizar por la primera vez
en la historia y esto quizá podría
responder en parte a ya la consolidación
de este cambio de paradigma económico
del capitalismo industrial donde surgen
los sindicatos al capitalismo de
plataformas en el que nos encontramos
hoy en día y es que como mencionábamos
uno de los ejemplos paradigmáticos es el
de amazon particularmente el de la sede
de staten island donde en abril de 2022
se creó el primer sindicato a luke por
la mansión playboy y unión las siglas en
inglés del sindicato de trabajadores de
amazon y precisamente en este artículo
que estamos viendo del diario punto es
traducido de the gardian y citan a un
trabajador de la sede de albany y que
entró a trabajar en amador en febrero y
dice después de una semana no podía
creer lo que veía no había suficientes
arneses para las personas no cabíamos
había lesiones era algo abrumador y
prosigue encontré que había un
importante interés por formar un
sindicato aunque también temores pero
los miedos se empezaron a disipar tras
la victoria en en el almacén de staten
island y cuando los trabajadores veían
su éxito a la hora de defender a otros
con los mismos problemas que ellos en
amazon rossi precisamente este efecto
contagio a esta gente entre las razones
que digamos explican la tendencia de la
organización laboral hasta ahora según
el medio económico estadounidense si en
vice exactamente que intenta dar las
razones de por qué se da ahora esta
tendencia al alza en términos de
organización a sindical como bien decías
por un lado cita este efecto contagio no
y es que por ejemplo en el caso de
starbucks atrás en la primera victoria
200 a 50 locales de starbucks hicieron
petición para sindicalizarse y 54 lo
consiguieron por otro lado la pandemia y
por otro lado también un efecto político
propicio por un lado el impulso de la
izquierda dentro del partido demócrata
incita como digamos cabezas visibles a
sanders oa ocasio cortes pero por otro
lado también recordemos a byd en que se
ha declarado abiertamente pero
movimiento sindical y es que vemos en la
siguiente imagen del business insider un
momento no que dio la vuelta a los
medios de comunicación internacionales
precisamente cuando badén se encontró
con crisis small en la casa blanca aquí
tenemos la foto y con ese titular no
eres el tipo de problema que me gusta no
hay que parar no para mencionar algunos
pues esto de estos ejemplos del momento
político propicio en eeuu no ya nos
quedamos con el caso de amazon porque
continúan las denuncias de abusos
laborales exactamente y esto es a lo que
hace referencia el medio especializado
en lucha sindical amor perfecto y unión
que titula en portada fotos revelan
trabajadores de amazon en remolques
abrasadores a 145 grados fahrenheit que
sería más de 60 grados celsius denuncian
los trabajadores pues turnos de 10 horas
sin las necesarias rotaciones y que la
dirección ignora sus peticiones de
solucionar esta situación por otro lado
este medio amor perfecto y unión señala
que los trabajadores hablan de forma
anónima por temor a las represalias y es
precisamente el temor a las represalias
también lo que impide a veces la
sindicalización y es que a pesar de que
el objetivo de un sindicato
'hemos es impedir los abusos laborales
por parte de las empresas y mejorar las
condiciones de los trabajadores sin
embargo o precisamente por esto las
victorias sindicales suceden a pesar de
la agresiva oposición muchas veces de
las multinacionales y vemos como este
mismo medio en un tuit revelaba algunas
de las campañas precisamente de amazon
para evitar que sus trabajadores se
quieran indicar lo vemos aquí nos signes
la carta de 'la u' que es el sindicato
de amazon no es fiable no está aprobado
etcétera bueno rosa vamos ahora con
algunos datos precisamente de las
tácticas anti sindicalistas de grandes
empresas esto lo vamos a ver en el texto
de el salto que hice radiografía del
sindicalismo en eeuu exactamente y nos
explica este texto que hay una gran
industria de consultorías y de bufetes
de abogados
especializados en impedir el movimiento
sindical litigando contra los sindicatos
o ofreciendo digamos estrategias a las
empresas y tenemos algunas cifras de lo
que pagan las grandes empresas la que
más ha según el informe que presenta el
salto es el la verdad el laboratorio
corporation of america que paga más de 4
millones entre otras pero tenemos otros
datos también del movimiento sindical
que nos ofrece esta radiografía del
salto como por ejemplo la aprobación
sindical desglosada por categorías
sociales los votantes del partido
demócrata aprueban hasta en un 90% los
sindicatos mientras que los republicanos
en un 47% también las personas
realizadas son más propensas a la
aprobación del movimiento sindical que
las blancas o los jóvenes más que los
grupos de más edad rosa también vamos a
ir con una entrevista que se le realizó
a uno de los fundadores de este
sindicato de amazon exactamente y el
medio también especializado en este en
esta ola de movimientos sindicales y así
precisamente se llama street wave pide a
connor spence uno de los fundadores del
sindicato de amazon del de staten island
como llegó a involucrarse en el
movimiento sindical y él responde un par
de meses después de que kris smoltz
fuera despedido crisis smoltz recordemos
el que veíamos en la imagen con bailén
y empezó a protestar en nueva york
frente al penthouse de jeff bezos en
manhattan me subí a un autobús fui a
reunirme con él para proponerle usar su
despido y transformarlo en un proyecto
organizativo para los trabajadores de
amazon el momento un político que
decíamos dice que quería juntar todo
este despido pues precisamente con el
malestar laboral por el cobit problema
otros problemas laborales también el
blacklight materno y le preguntan y que
te impulsó a hacer esto no a el
bus e ir a buscar a chris moyles dice
espero durante mucho tiempo a que
viniera un sindicato establecido a
organizar a amazon pero luego me di
cuenta de que no es así como funciona
los trabajadores tienen que hacerlo
ellos mismos y por último le preguntan
cómo te sentiste cuando te enteraste de
la victoria en la elección sindical y el
honor spence responde obviamente estaba
feliz pero fue raro porque realmente
nunca concebimos perder el fracaso no
era una opción para nosotros